hi everyone my name is vincent i'll be
your mc for this evening um or morning
depends on where you are
um
and also in terms of mc i will also be
your pimc3 uh
mc joke
um we'll just wait for like a couple of
minutes before people are able actually
to come in but this will be a good time
for
dana to start setup
as the first speaker
but the way that this is going to work
is um you have between like five and ten
minutes uh if you are very close to the
ten minute mark uh i will have to start
playing sound that's going to go
increasingly louder uh just as like a
gentle hint that you are over time
um but i am genuinely kind of excited
about the stuff that you're going to
talk about so
uh without further ado um first of all
collapse donna uh please take it away
thank you
so before i start i just want to make a
small disclaimer so no one is
disappointed today
if
this lecture is not for you if you
always implement the most cutting-edge
solution and never think about a simple
one
this lecture is also not for you if
you're completely blind to the client's
needs
and if you cannot see the big picture
you better just move on if business kpis
make you fall asleep we better separate
now
if talking to the product manager
make you feel sick you better just move
on
and if
everything looks like a nail for you
this lecture is not for you and you
better move to the next lecture
but if you stay so far hop on board
because i'm going to take you to a
fascinating journey together today
so hi i'm dana i'm the head of data
science at pikapir
i also serve as a data science advisor
for various startups
and my biggest passion
is solving hard problems with the most
simple solution i can find
so our journey today
actually starts 20 years ago when this
was a very common picture when you had
to go to an uh tourist agency in order
to book your flights
luckily today you don't need to book
your flight by going physically to an
agency but you can just
book it online and even pick your seats
for the inventory um for the marina
world this is how
the inventory system looked like 20
years ago
and
this is how it looks today that is the
exact same thing
i mean until we at pikipur entered the
picture
so at pikapira started by working we
actually
tried to solve and all the problems that
skippers and marinas has
like communicating with each other
making reservations and managing
the inventory
but today actually i want to um talk
with you about a specific problem
uh the matching problem the problem i
had to solve when i first got to pick a
peer like a year and a half ago
so um the matching problem is matching
between
upcoming reservation and a birthing spot
so while i was thinking about this
problem i actually realized it's kind of
similar to a tattoo scheme
like in the tetris game
when you don't know which shape you're
going to get next the same is for
marinas they never know
which boat is going to reserve a spot
next and they need to plan ahead
so before i reveal my algorithm i just
want to share the product requirements
the first one
was first
first comes first served meaning that we
actually don't running are not running a
maf here and if a boat
was promised a spot when it gets to it
gets to the marina we want to make sure
it has a spot to birthing
the second assumption was that we want
to allocate the specific birth
only a day before a boat arrives the
reason is to keep the flexibility
for the marina
so in order to meet this product
assumptions i had requirements i had to
make some algorithmic assumptions
first algorithmic assumption was that
the number of burning spots inside a
marina is a constant number
because it's not not an easy task to
just add a peer inside a marina
second assumption was that the cost
function of my algorithm should be very
flexible in order to meet different
requirements for different marinas
meaning some arena want to optimize
their occupancy some of marinas want to
optimize their prestige and some of the
marines want to optimize their uh maybe
revenue
the last assumption was that although i
really wanted to
implement a reinforcement planning
i actually had only some kind of few
dozen of samples
when i started first to work on this
algorithm
so back to the tetris game what if while
i'm playing i just could take the shape
i got just got and swap it
with a shape that already exists in the
screen in order to optimize score
so this is exactly what i did in
pikapi's matching algorithm before we
dive in just to want to let you know
that behind the scene
is there is a
very um complex mathematical equation
but i cannot share with you today
because it's a pending patent
but i can share with you all the flow
so before i say the flow just to let you
know the blue color represent the
waiting list the reservation pool the
mustard color represent
the matches
the purple color represents the
available birds so like that let's dive
in
we'll start with a common practice today
final reservation first arrive to a
marina by phone or by email
um the receptionist can just look out of
the window and save those available bed
if no available belt is found the
reservation is rejected and usually no
waiting list is offered
but in pikapur's algorithm something
different happens let's dive
inside
so in pekipere's algorithm
when a reservation gets automatically
through our system uh the matching
algorithm tries to find uh this
reservation and make a match for with
available birth
if no match is found the reservation
goes inside a reservation waiting list
but if a match is found we do another
the algorithm does another optimization
step by trying to swap uh this match
with already existing
matches and if
this swap would optimize
the cost function it would be made
and now a boat a would be matched to
bird b and boat b would be matched to
birth a
last but not least is the following part
actually this is this was the most
important part that made the most
difference in the optimization process
if a bird become available for example
if someone cancel this reservation
then the algorithm tries to match
disperse to a reservation from the
waiting list
if a matching is found we're going back
to the matching cascade i described
before but if no match is found we still
have a free bird
and the algorithm tries to swap it
with an already matched bird
and then the new match is going inside
the the pool the match that most
optimize the cons function
so i think so far i actually managed to
convince you that i've created a very
simple it was made by with python a very
simple algorithm
that actually meets all the requirements
the product
asks me
and fits perfectly to our maritime
domain
industry
so i just want to finish with this
lovely
meme of paige bailey
tell me the truth
i'm i'm ready to hear it
most of the time you won't need deep
learning
you won't even need machine learning
thank you so much
thanks for the lightning talk there um
then next up we've got jeremy so jeremy
i'm going to now
ask you to unmute and if you could get
the screen ready uh in the meantime what
i would like to do is just share a poem
that someone shared with me on slack
yesterday
roses are red my data is blue watch what
i can do with an eigenvalue
okay i thought it was i thought it was
kind of clever but um having said that
uh jeremy i think you are now able to
uh speak just to double check
yeah sure
okay you're good okay perfect uh then
jeremy um
take it away
okay
thank you
it started when i've created a python
script to organize and clean nest
extraordinary data for my project
or in short data wrangling
[Music]
when people in the lab realize that i
can write in python many assume that i
know every single programming language
there is and asked me to troubleshoot
our python or best script created by
past collaborators that meant to do
similar tasks as mine
this workload got me overwhelmed as
troubleshooting these scripts could be
time consuming and i do not have the
time to do important things in research
to make myself more efficient i combine
all these scripts into one window
executable software in python called ms
organizer
looking back i realized that things have
not been easy
this is because in academia
most of us are not trained in coding or
software development it is hard for us
to write software for our own research
paper
it is even more challenging to create
software for others to use as how daniel
blocks puts it using food as an energy
cooking your own food is a lot easier
than being a chef in a restaurant
[Music]
while implementation in python may sound
simple for some a lot of time is spent
to make it user friendly for people with
limited computing experience
and i hope my sharing is helpful to
those who are doing a similar task as me
so my first advice is to invest some
time to learn how to create to convert
scripts to web services so executable
software's like mine
asking my lab members to run scripts
using command line was just too hard and
frustrating for them
the picture on the left was my
experience in the past oh jeremy i tried
to run this script from collaborator but
since python is not found can you help
me and then after installing python all
its libraries we still have to figure
out how the script works and could only
run it after many trials and errors due
to lack of documentation
on the other hand with the software with
this green interface and telling us
clear instructions on what to do
it could save us a lot of time to do the
things that we need
to make this executable program i use
chris gui to create a simple green
interface quickly and then py installer
to convert the script to a standalone
executable program
i understand that things are easier said
than done so i include jack mchugh's
blog which helped me as a starting point
to make use of these two tools to get
what i need
initially my 2 was a simple program that
has a 3 page manual
however as i add more feature requests
he has turned to this monster that
requires a 30-image manual
understandably how to use it
this made new users overwhelmed when
they see it for the first time doing
comments like i'm scared it's confusing
maybe this tool is not for me
[Music]
to make things less intimidating i
created a cheat sheet to give an
overview of what my software does rather
than just drawing to the new users my 30
page manual
you may refer to our studio website for
their cheat sheet examples
powerpoint templates
and advice on how to create these good
cheat sheets
no software is perfectly free from
errors and bugs likewise no human being
is perfect and can sometimes make
mistakes
unfortunately people do not like
python's default errors like this
because it is too technical for them to
understand
it is hard for the perspective to know
if the problem lies with the input data
or the software
and this area below was caused because
of the software trying to output the
results on the file that is currently in
use by the user himself so what i did is
to make the error more helpful and it
does go a long way because users can
mostly solve the issues by themselves so
for the same error i put unable to save
excel file because of permission errors
please close the file if it's still open
on your computer
then try running the software again
i am grateful to sadia's blog for
reminding me that the users can perform
an incorrect action again and again but
it is the design's responsibility to
inform him about about his mistakes in a
good way
and if someone comes to you and comments
that your error message is unclear
may i suggest michael's advice
and tell them what changes would be
helpful
this worked for me as well because it
sounds less offensive to the user and
shows that you're open to criticism it
also encourages users to give
suggestions and constructive feedback in
turn doing the work for you
the fourth advice is to include
necessary software reports to show
reliability
today academic journals are getting more
demanding with regards to software run
wanting reusability besides
reproducibility
it requests code to be easier to install
and able to run with new data and
parameters as well
so here are some tips that help my code
or software better to meet these
standards
one you can take a label on different
software versions
and encourage users to cite not just
your software name but the version's
number as well and i usually put my
executable softwares my different
versions in the release part in github
and release and x assets
so you can also create a report file to
store your user input parameters
and for me i create this pdf file using
chris example using w easy print but
there are also other examples such as
net
lastly if possible you can show
pre-processing results to explain how
the software calculates the final
results
they are helpful when there's a need to
troubleshoot for logical areas
for my case i need to explain to
collaborator from a different science
background how i generated my output
values
i initially tried to explain using
formulas from journal papers but it did
not work so what i did in my software is
that this optional settings to create
additional excel sheets in ping
and then i tell the collaborators that
to get this sheet you just take the area
sheet divided by this internal standard
area sheet and then explain how these
values are created
and now it comes to documentation
documentation is important because it
tells others how the software works and
how it is built
it helps to prevent technical depths
especially one taking over the software
maintenance is less experienced than you
[Music]
i started writing down by following some
advice by these articles such as
including examples and quick start
guides
but the mistake i made is that i put
everything into one single word file
with many chapters
as you can see in the books that i have
and in the end
as my documentation starts to get longer
and more complex people find it hard to
navigate and find relevant information
and in turn hard to understand even even
myself
so thankfully i came across dvo websites
that encouraged me to split my
documentations into manageable
categories like
tutorials how to guides explanations and
reference
following its footsteps and having to
clean up after myself this is what i
meant to come up with
so for the tutorials i put in my github
readme
how to guides i many put that in my
cheat sheets
and for the explanations for the
nitty-gritty stuff like this json file
and what is it used for i put in the
user documentation
and for these hardcore python scripts
and their structures and organizations i
put them in the developers documentation
lastly a small ticker advice
create a software that gives a lasting
impact even if it's for a small group of
users
when creating a software
we want to create something that
impressed a lot of people or make it to
a journal paper or even this conference
however we tend to forget that the main
purpose for creating a software is not
to make us popular it is to help others
with their problems
a problem no matter how small can be as
annoying as big ones
the more annoying the problem the
software tries to solve the more useful
it is
the things that have software that my
software does are actually very simple
but it helps my let members reduce the
tedious workload of manually copy and
pasting data and creating hard-coded
formulas from multiple excel sheets
which are very error prone
so don't feel discouraged when you are
task or arrow to create a tool that does
small and simple things
instead do these things with great love
and as this blog post from equations
says if you can impact a few people
deeply they will shuffle the rooftops
for you
the breath of the impact will be a
matter of time so just be patient and
continue to improve along the way
and that's it
thank you all for listening
all the best and enjoy the rest of the
conference
okay thanks for that um if the next
speaker could please sit up this will be
uh and again i for instance correctly uh
so i will now
move the cat off of my
keyboard
to give you permission
so guys this is pranav company and i'm a
researcher in vitab which is a
university in india and today uh i'll
just share you guys about what i created
which is a podcast somewhere called
gargantuar and gargantuan the the name
is small not to uh the black hole and
interstellar because it just keeps
eating a lot of stuff so this podcast
summarizes a while training each sort of
data
so uh
i mean
can you see my screen sorry
hello
yeah so i can see uh oh now you've moved
back to the zoom
and i can see your screen
yeah so yep so the entire talk yeah yeah
so sorry for the interruption anyway so
uh so this talk i'm going to talk about
how i leverage sequence sequence
learning for sending out portfolios so
me and my friend gotham wanted to create
a machine which could just take podcasts
uh do summarize and then send out
newsletters to people the way you get
your uh
blog or newsletters or the way you get
your new york times or any of the news
articles and you get a proper
information information so we wanted to
create a review system for podcasts of
people to understand for people to
figure out which podcast they want to
hear or know which episode they want to
hear just depending on the summary of it
so uh so before i go into the cream of
it this is an example of what gargantuar
generated so this is a very good podcast
uh on being by uh christa tippett and
it's a really good one so and then and
then we took an episode of uh nami shay
and then we ran the
so i'll just organization for like two
seconds here two three seconds for you
guys let me take a screenshot or you
know take a look at it
so this is completely machine generated
or this is completely generated by the
uh abstractive summarizer so how does
this happen
so first it's a very simple thing this
is the fundamental thing this is
something everyone would do which is i
take an episode and i
convert into simple text or you know
into a text document using google asr or
you know google. speech to text
recognition
and then after this i take the entire
text document on youtube and share the
generator summary so although it sounds
simple let me talk about what gargantuar
is so gargantuary is partly
uh inspired by uh pegasus by google i
mean pegasus model by google which is
also an abstractive summarizer and then
this we've developed uh so we've we've
developed gargantuar for a company
called as uh rapid dot ai who's who's
based in which is based in germany so uh
uh since i can't let out the insights of
what happens in encode and decoder but
i'm pretty i'm sure all of you know what
an encoder is it takes sentences or it
takes input and converts them to high
dimensional
vectors so this pretty much does the
same then recorder is just the same
which takes in the context vector and
then decodes it to find uh the desired
text so what we've done is we've taken
the transcript
faded to the encoder wherein uh it is
converted into a physical representation
of vectors by the context that are given
to the encoder decoder which tries to
generate a summary which is almost or
nearby to what is written in the
transcript
so however to train this uh however to
train this it's a big pain in the as
i'll tell you why because
data preparation is huge so for for this
we've uh we've signed the spontaneous
contract of getting over one lakh
podcast episodes and then yeah each
podcast is around sorry each episode is
around 12 to 15 minutes in it and then
the average length is around 3000 to
5000 words so this is a data set which
we brought from podcast now we wanted to
generate a reference summary or a
data set for the model to train or eat
on so what we've done is we've taken
every episode then they've generated
extractive uh summaries multiple
platforms using various models available
on huggingface.com
and then what we've done is we've
calculated the rock score for every uh
uh summary generated using extractive
submarine and then uh for people who
don't know what rock score is rock score
is a metric used by uh or i mean yeah
used by a lot of professionals to
determine the accuracy of a summary
generated by a machine so then we've
calculated the rock scores for every uh
extractive summary generated after which
we have taken the rock summary sorry the
rock score of the
uh with the highest value from the
summary generated and then we've
corresponded that to the particular
travel trip so this this we did for
almost over uh uh a one lakh or a
hundred thousand episodes after which
then they've come up come up with this
concept of lock and key
block wherein the lock is the transcript
and the key is the reference argument so
the reference memory is the desired
output you or the you you want from the
model and then there's a transcript or
whatever the input you could give it
which is around three to five k inwards
so this is so this entire block is fed
to the
model in the following manner so instead
of input text i'm giving it the
transcript to uh giving a transcript to
the encoder and then instead of uh
i mean any other summary giving the
reference something to a decoder to
match it and then see if it can generate
something nearby so this this training
was done for over two hundred trainer
epochs so after this what we realized
that uh
you can you can do abstract summary to a
point which is good but not better so
what we did is we've gone back to square
one which is here and then instead of
calculating the rock the highest rock
score we've taken the second highest
rock score and then uh and and i did the
same process of training it on 200 to
train at epochs after which we've got
some really great results
so uh gargantuar training is simple
which is uh we take the latest uh or
what exactly gargantuar does at the end
of the day is it takes the latest
podcast episode transfer through the
model and first of the model generates a
summary so that is what happens
in uh gargantuar and after which we have
created into initiative or an api
wherein users who subscribe to a
particular
episode or report so
subscribe to a particular podcast can
use or leverage gargantuar just
subscribe uh to the service and then
they can just wait for weekly needed to
come wherein the api takes in different
uh podcast episodes and then converts
them into summary and then provides it
to the user in the form of an email
so this is another example of what
gargantuan shared in a single shot uh
inference which is it did not uh so it
took
tim
ferriss's uh
episode which is around 1 hour 44
minutes which has over 15 plus of 15 000
18 000 words in it and then it has done
single shot summary and it has come to
this point so this is the raw text which
has been generated by gargantua without
any
uh text cleaning or etc
so i'll just pause it for like five
seconds five six seconds if you guys
want to have a look at it
so what we found was the the results
were absolutely amazing and then this is
something which every podcast creator
would want to use
so
so this is pranav and thanks a lot uh uh
cheers to uh gotham garanda who's also a
co-author in this project i'm sorry i
couldn't share any problems because of
the
confidential information but i'm ready
to
uh share any other notebooks of uh
google pegasus or the light version of
gargantuar about release thanks a lot
thanks a lot vincent okay uh thanks for
that was interesting and the next
speaker uh
i'm going to put you on the uh on mute
now
uh asked to unmute um and that means
that you should be able to start sharing
your screen
very good take it away
so hi i'm
and i'm going to talk about my open
source project improving accessibility
for data science with graph
solidification library
as back as fast as background i think in
order to realize a diverse astrology
it is important that all people learn
data science not just experts
if there is a lack of diversity in the
air development process
the air system will encourage division
among people or have unintended
consequences
therefore in order to realize the ideal
air society many people will need to be
involved in data data science
nowadays it is called ai for everyone
etc so you may have heard of it
and actually many organizations and
countries are just beginning to work on
this
however
visually impaired people who rely on
screen reader to navigate computed
face many difficulties in learning data
science
because visual representations are often
used in data science as you know
therefore i'm developing a graph
certification library that will help
people to understand data without
relying on visual representation in data
science
the graph that graph certification
python library is named audio program
it can easily convert data such as that
displayed in a graph into audio
representation
you can install it via pip and try it
out easily
this is an example of compiling
converting a simple series of data on
google privacy
enter graph
[Music]
x is 3 y is 3
leave graph
[Music]
x is three why is three
if you are able to use the mouse cursor
you can trace the
shape
shape of the graph to listen to the
pitch of the audio and you can also
click on it to check the value at that
position
if you are only using the keyboard you
can still use the slider to do the same
thing
alternatively if you don't need
interactivity and just want to check the
glass easily it also has audio playback
minimum value is zero
maximum value is three
line
[Music]
one you can also combat multiple graphs
at the same time and compare them
for example in this way you can check
how well the linear relation is fitting
enter data and best fit line label zero
is selected double click to change
this is a sound for blue dot line blue
dot data
label one is selected and this is this
one is for rain line data
[Music]
so it sounds like it fits well
in addition it has a variety of other
options such as the option to set up
separate accesses for comparison
like crime graph
finally based on the graph sonification
library introduced in this presentation
i published data science learning
content for the visually impaired
in particular for japanese students who
have the opportunity to study data
science in their classes
we are working on creating comprehensive
content that includes an introduction to
development environment programming
fundamentals and etc
with the cooperation of the visual
impaired students
the improvement i have introduced in
this pronunciation is only one component
of unresolved accessibility issues in
data science
therefore i welcome any feedback to help
them improve those situations thank you
for watching
thanks for that lightning talk
next up is meshfa i'm clicking the ask
to unmute button as we speak so you
should be able to share the screen and
in the meantime i have an interesting
question um to the crowd like does
anyone know why tesla's cost so much you
know the very popular car they're really
popular but they cost a lot do we know
why
it's because they charge a lot
[Music]
yep that's looking good so uh
patel how about pronounce your name
correctly you're going to be talking
about data analytics in healthcare yes
very good take it away
yes it's very well visible take it away
thank you thank you so much um good
morning everyone it's good morning here
and thank you so much for coming here
and i'm ishva and i'll be completing my
bachelor's uh uh next year and so this
is a talk about how i like to use data
science and analytics and healthcare
basically
and um so let's get forward with it
so there are four main types of data
analytics that we could do in healthcare
sectors and in general
so first one is the descriptive one
where we identify patterns from
historical data understand the why and
what actually happened and in the
diagnostic data analysis what we do is
we identify the causes the correlation
and understand what actually happened
and what actually caused the event
and the predictive type of data analysis
we find out what is the likelihood of
something that is going to happen in the
future
and
it focuses on correlation and
statistical analysis understanding
likelihood of future outcomes
and in prescriptive type of data
analytics we find out what is the best
course of action that could be taken by
an individual or an organization
for
like strategy
steps and decision making systems
so how do we use data analytics for
healthcare so there are four main
sectors where we'd be using uh
healthcare and then combining data
analytics to healthcare
first one is the clinical one where we
use ehr and medical images for
identifying patient diseases and
symptoms
and understanding what uh like suppose
even if there's an adverse event coming
up or some anomaly that is going in the
vitals
and then an administrative type of
data analytics of health care we find
out about costs the reimbursement how is
the finance looking how is the patient
characteristics or equipment
requirements suppose if there's a
predictive maintenance that is going to
happen
then the patient behavior and sentiment
we collect data from variable sensors
and social sites to identify whether
some flu outbreak is going to happen in
the future or it's happening right now
and pharmaceuticals where we find out if
there is like a target behavior like how
the target behavior is performing
according to all the other data points
that we have right now
so let me just
give you a brief dive into
some of the research work that was taken
by me and then we'll see how these type
of data analytics is used
for healthcare basically
and the first one i'd like to talk here
is outlier detection for clinical drug
trials so here the i show a plot of how
uh there's an anomaly and then the
yellow ones are the anomalies and the
blue ones are the one that is uh that is
okay my
uh it's a drug called placebo and
dossier taxes
where i visualize a 3d trust me plot for
finding out the anomalies in the
clinical drug trials
and the second one shows up for 2d
visuals of an outlier of where a like a
magnesium is being plotted about how you
know there are two data data outliers
over here so we can find out that what
actually is happening and what is the
data point that is an outlier here and
why is it happening so a visualization
gives a better understanding of
what are the anomalies present in the
trials
so that is first place where we use
clinical drug trials and to go a bit
deeper inside this the first the plot
here is actually using iso isolation
forest for identifying the outliers here
and the second this uh 2d visual show a
simple uh like a plotting area where we
put uh
where we can identify the two of the
outliers here
so it does not use any uh
uh algorithm here but we can see when we
visualize the data of healthcare we can
see that there are two sort of points
that are that stand out from the other
data
then the second case where we can use
administrative data i mean the data
visualization is an administrative
department here is a dashboard showing
that how and what is the average
patient waiting time the patient
satisfaction this can help improving the
patient experience and formulate
staffing requirements and scheduling for
them and it can also if this was for a
maintenance of equipment we could
identify how much there's a requirement
or the shortage of equipment and it can
also if this was implemented for uh like
a patient it could also help in
identifying each ehr system means like
electronic health records for each and
every
patient that is available and who comes
to the doctor
then we can also identify the pandemic
outlook through through data
visualization this could help in
bringing out awareness and impactful
visualization for public awareness
so this was done for covid presently as
uh and this would be a good thing for
like organizations like you who and you
and to put forward this kind of visual
visualization to understand what is
really happening around the world
and the fourth one
it actually visualizes the patient data
where uh a person was a person was
tested on parkinson's disease of the
people who don't know parkinson's it's
basically a kind of disease where uh you
know you don't have a sort of nervous
uh
nervous system interaction with the how
the body moves basically your brain
thinks something else but your body does
not move according to that
so it affects your nervous system so
here a patient data is being visualized
about how around four three activities
sleeping resting and moving
and the calibrations are being plotted
and the vitals are being visualized here
so and then also kind of it helps in
understanding how a patient process
progress in the disease actually happens
through the stages
so another future work of data
visualization in health care
as some statistics notes that it's going
to increase so what it holds for the
enterprises and the healthcare
institutions is developing better tools
and libraries such as open home health
visualizations to create a robust data
pipelines
the second thing is inculcating and
developing cloud technology for
accessing and sharing patient records
through the in health institutions
and also eliminating bias and
discrimination and data just like how we
saw for outlier detection we could also
eliminate and find out the bias
happening in the data and forecast it on
the go
so thank you so much if you have any
questions please do
ask me and then thank you so much have a
great day
okay uh thanks a bunch for that um so
next up would be
elana
okay so hi i'm milana i'm a senior
researcher at zoom info previously
chorus.ai and today i'm going to talk
about productizing web to back 2.0
so first a quick intro about the company
zoom info provides sales organizations
with a complete suite of tools for
managing every b2b go to market action
starting with marketing understanding
intensive companies
reaching out and engaging customers and
understanding how to have better
conversations
course was recently acquired by zoom
info
what we do is that we enable sales
representatives to be the best version
of themselves by unlocking the data in
calls
we'll record 60 million hours of
conversations this year and we expect
that number to double next year
as a conversation intelligence platform
transcription is a basic data point and
one of the main focus of our research
team
most of the insights we provide are
based on transcribed conversations
therefore it's really important because
the better the transcription the better
all the results following it
so what's asr asr stands for automatic
speech recognition and the purpose is to
find the most likely sequence of words
given a sound signal
for a long time hybrid models comprised
of hidden markov chain based ms and
gaussian mixture models gmns were the
mainstream speech recognition frameworks
however recently end-to-end systems like
work to red using deep neural networks
have achieved higher performance
here on the right of the slide you can
see the architecture of a hybrid system
first an acoustic model is used to
predict phonemes from mfcc's
the model can be either an hmm gmm model
and hmm dnn model
and then the phonemes are converted to
words using a pronunciation dictionary
together with a language model
ref to back is one of the most prominent
end-to-end systems it was developed by
facebook
the main advantage of this model is that
most of the training is made on
unlabeled data
it uses self-supervised learning to
convert speech auto into vector
representations
and then you can fine tune the model
using labeled data to convert those
representations into either words or
phonemes
so deep neural networks take a lot of
data to train labeled data is hard to
get it's expensive and it's time
consuming
learning good speech representations on
huge amounts of unlabeled data allows us
to achieve high precision in specific
domains with limited label
data on the right you can see some of
the results from the facebook paper
the model achieves state-of-the-art
performance on maybe speech cleaning
other test sets
this is what the architecture of the
model looks like first the raw audio is
passed through cnn layers to get latent
representations
then product quantization is applied to
those representations
once you have the quantized vectors you
pass them through a transformer to get
the context representations
during the training
about half of the quantized
representations are masked before being
fed into the transformer
and then the output is optimized using
contrastive loss
then for fine tuning we don't use
quantization instead we apply a linear
projection layer to the unmasked output
of the transformer to get the
probability distribution over the tokens
by tokens i mean either letter of
phonemes
okay now i'll move on to productizing
website what we did is that we used
facebook's pre-trained model that we
then fine-tuned on our own sales in the
main data
one thing to note is that fair sec
the git supports different language
models and grams and transformers and
there's also an option to use viterbi
decoding without a language model
in our case we fine-tuned the model
using ctc loss with our own engram
language model
we used the faircep code from facebook
but we made several adjustments in order
to be able to train in our own data
and the way that we did this is by
writing new classes that inherit from
the fairfaq ones
and then just making changes to specific
functions
to look at the code on the slide on the
left you have the first training task
and on the right is our own task class
which inherits from the first deck one
so now first explain how to prepare the
data and how we adjusted the code to
work with our own data and then i'll
talk about how we dealt with one of the
limitations of wax evac
the model is trained on 15 second
segments
for training you need the data photo to
contain the following files the
dick.ltr.txt is just the list of the
tokens so in our case it's uppercase
letters and an end of word tokens
the other files contains the data for
the segmented audio and each file
corresponds to one segment
the order of the segments should be
consistent throughout the files
the tsv files contain the path to the
audio wav files
if you want to train it's important that
you keep that naming otherwise you'll
need to make changes to the code
since we transcribed sales calls our
data consists of a wav file for an
entire call together with its matching
transcript
the first thing we needed to do is to
segment the data or in other words to
split the audio into 15 second segments
and then align the transcript words to
that segmented audio this is a hard
problem and to do it we use the kalvi
scripts
the library speech data has a separate
audio file for each segment
so i had to adapt the dataset code to
use specific portion of the website
and once again i did it by writing a new
data set class in inheritance
knowing what were said when essential
for a product as we need it for speaker
separation to create playlists and many
other features
first uses a decoder from the flashlight
git which is written in c plus
trying to get the times by making
changes to the decoder itself sounded
complicated and time consuming and we
didn't want to do this as we work mostly
in python we found the simplest solution
by hacking the first python code that
calls the decoder
so if you look at the code for the
decoding function you can see that the c
plus plus decoder doesn't only return
the decoded words but also the predicted
token for time step for the best path
we use the stride and kernel size of the
convolution layers and the sample rate
of the audio in order to calculate the
time in seconds corresponding to each
time step
you can see what it looks like in the
table at the top and the blue is a
representation of the ctc output each
cell represents one times f
the first row is just the index of the
time steps then underneath you can see
the time in seconds that we calculated
and the output token
the s symbol that you see is a blank
symbol and it's needed for ctc in order
to
be able to have words with repeating
letters
to get the predicted word sequence you
need to collect repeated labels in the
output sequence
then you can split
the sequencing of tokens into words
using the end of word token
okay so at this point what we have we
have timings together with word letter
sequences or what we call the word
spellings
it's a language model lexicon that
contains the mapping from the word to
the spellings you can see what it looks
like on the bottom left
but for the purpose of transcription we
need the word itself and not just the
spelling
because several words can have the same
spelling and we need to be able to
differentiate words like am or m
otherwise the transcript wouldn't be
readable
during the decoding itself the best word
for spelling is chosen using the lm
score
so for us the easier way the easiest way
to get the words is to map the word
spellings to the output words for the
decoder
and add the corresponding times to the
decoded words
once you do that you're done
you have your ref to back output with
the timings
so that's it for today we're about to
release our own wife2vec model the
production and we're very excited to
improve our transcription quality
thanks for um thanks for that talk it's
always nice to see that
python goes beyond tabular data these
days so that's always
very cool to see indeed um we are going
to be moving on to the next speaker so
in this case uh cheve i'm going to ask
you to oh uh on mute at the moment
um
and if you get unmute so we can see you
in screen i can see the slide
uh everyone this is jave take it away
all right thank you so much uh so again
welcome everyone to pi data google 2021
i'm shivaya and i'm going to be
presenting a talk on using telstra js
converter to be able to convert python
based machine learning models into
javascript based machine learning marks
and a very quick introduction about
myself i am currently at installation
company working group member and also
doing some food mentor for tensorflow
and media bike if you want to connect
with me you can connect me on hard
development
now first of all
the most important addition of
insulators itself so it originally
started out as a deep learning.js
library and uh this was built as an open
source library by google intense
floating and the most important thing is
that we want to convert python based
models into javascript-based machine
learning models and the need for that
was that a lot of times creative
professionals or developers who might be
working on web development might not
necessarily
know python or machine learning so to be
able to actually just utilize machine
learning models in their applications uh
we can allow for converting python based
machine learning models directly into a
javascript based machine learning models
that can be used directly with
javascript and with web applications so
tensorflow.js comes primarily with uh
two different kinds of apis that
includes the core and the layers api and
we can also build completely new machine
learning models directly in javascript
and also retain some of the existing
ones that might have been written in
python and uh it also uses basically
both your cpu and gpu for all the
training and influence that that
actually takes place and also has
support for not just on browser machine
learning to be actually taking place
that is on the client side but also on
the server side by using node
and one of the biggest reasons why
javascript is becoming so popular is
that it can actually run virtually
everywhere it could be on the browser
server uh on desktop
using its electron js on mobile using
mac native or even on iot using uh
node.js with mic uh let's say raspberry
pi
and
that what makes a javascript so much
popular in terms of its versatility uh
to be actually used in all these
different kinds of platforms and that is
why we are trying to also be able to see
that either we can use some of the uh
machine learning models that have been
directly converted from python into
javascript or we can also use a transfer
learning to
run some of the existing models to
actually get trained over on your own
data or you can directly actually write
machine learning models in javascript
that you can use
and of course um all of us might be
aware of what exactly is transfer
learning being able to actually just go
ahead and utilize some of the
pre-existing models and retrain over
them on your own data to make them more
optimized for your workflows that you
might be having and similarly uh
tensorflow.js also allows you to create
your own machine learning models now
basically now how we have the tensorflow
and keras in python so we have
essentially two different types of apis
one is the layers api that is very
similar to
us and then we have the low level api
that is more sort of um where you can
actually do a lot of different
mathematical transformations such as uh
just write uh your own code of neural
algebra uh and that's basically the
opposite and just to understand uh it
from a high level perspective we have at
the top we have the pre-built models or
the models that have been converted from
python then we have the layers api and
at the end we have the course api and
you can run it both on the client side
and on the server side using cpu webgl
and web assembly on the client side uh
directly being able to run machine
learning models without having to have a
dedicated server for example being able
to host your machine learning model on
let's say a django based server directly
actually being able to run on client
side or you can also run it on server
side by using node.js bindings
and uh this is how basically we are also
able to use either some of the keras
models or we can use tfgs converter that
we are going to be talking about today
for actually being able to convert
python based models into javascript
models and that's what is really
the main prospect of the core and uh the
layers api so with the course api uh you
are writing basically the machine models
directly in javascript and similarly
with layers api it's highly inspired by
keras of how keras epilep works in
python so that's what the layers api is
talking about so finally coming on to
the tf just converter that is the
tensorflow guest converter so let's say
you have a python based machine model
you have written in python so it could
either be in a keras format it could be
a in a tensorflow based format so
tensioner just allows you to sort of
test this converter allows you to
basically convert those pre-drained tens
flow and keras based models into a
web-friendly format we'll be just also
going over what is that format exactly
and essentially what we are doing is
that we can take one of your tensorflow
saved models or the model could also be
there on tensorflow hub so let's say you
have created a python script that is
used for creating machine learning
modeling you can directly just convert
it into a test flow save model or to a
dot h5 format save format and you can
directly just convert it into a
model.json file that has all the
characteristics of the machine on the
model using the tensorflow guest
converter and directly just run it into
the browser and run inference with the
help of then flowcase and usually this
is the input format that you will have
so basically the command is attention to
this underscore converted and then you
provide the input format it could be a
tf safe model it could be a h5 keras
based model it could be a th half based
model and then you give basically the
output format of whether it is a graph
based model or it's uh the tensor uh
model and then you just have to give the
path where the model uh that you want to
convert into is given and finally just
have to give a path where you would
actually want to save the output again
this output would be a model.json file
that has all the configurations of the
machine learning model that you have
just created
and these are some of the features that
are actually supported by tensorflow.js
so you can either use the safe model you
can use a force in graph you can use an
hdf file format which is again a file
format that is used by keras or you can
also use it as flow hub modulus
and again it's really simple so just
take a tensorflow save model or
s5 model or a tensorflow based model and
just convert that into the model.json
file and use that monitor model.json
file with your javascript or your web
based project that has been primarily
built in javascript so this let's have a
very quick demo of what we are trying to
build so over here i have an ipython
file that i have just created i'll just
quickly load it up and i'll quickly
share so basically this ipython file uh
essentially has
my uh model that i have created uh where
i'm just taking a pima uh data set that
is the main means diabetes data set
where i'm trying to find out whether a
person will have likelihood of actually
getting diabetes or not so i've just
used a keras based model where i've
taken a data set from a csv file and
i've just used basically um a basic uh
you know keras based uh deep learning
model where i'm using the sequential
model and then i'm just adding a few
layers on top of it and i'm using uh
basically the adam optimizer and also uh
binary loss binary processing property
for the losses function and then i'm
just
running it to fit on my dataset that i
have and finally once the model actually
runs um we can see that basically what
i've done is i have saved it into a tfgs
slash underscore model.s5 file format
and once this is done the training takes
place uh then we have a total of 150
epochs and then what i'm doing is that
i'm just installing uh the
package that is the tensorflow.jsp
package and once i've done this um what
i do is i run my command of the tense
through this underscore converter where
i've given the input format i scared us
and uh then i have given uh the input
file that i have basically after i had
successfully been able to train my model
where i've converted into a dot h5
format and the output where i want where
i want to actually store it is basically
the dfjs underscore model so once you
actually run this command you will
basically find these two different files
over here one is the model.json file
this small.json file basically has the
configuration of the entire uh machine
and model where you can actually see
that it's basically the keras model and
it is converted by the controllers
converter and it will provide you all
the different um model topologies and
you'll also basically generate the
weights of your uh model by uh which you
can see over here that is the group one
shot of one basically this is your uh
weights of the machine involved you can
directly just now embed this particular
model in your in a javascript file and
start using it so the biggest reason why
we are actually doing this is that a lot
of times even if we are doing some kind
of a data science project um we might be
actually wanting to actually showcase it
in a web-based format so instead of
directly
running that uh you know um python based
like machine learning data science study
that you might have done you have an
alternative to actually convert that
model that you might have built for a
design study that you have made into a
javascript format and just
very easily visualize it so without
having to set up a dedicated flask based
server or a django based python server
where you're running your machine
learning model you can directly convert
it into javascript and start using it
with a really interactive web
application because on the javascript
side as well you have a lot of different
tools that you mean really that can be
really used to showcase your data
science studies we have a lot of
different uh things such as uh d3.js
that is used for uh like you know for
showing a lot of different types of
visualizations so it's really just very
easy to
do your study of data science in python
then once you have done that study you
are converting it into a machine
learning model uh right and uh you can
save that machine learning model with
any kind of file format whether it's a
tensorflow format or uh basically uh
let's say keras based model and you can
convert it into a tensorflow model uh in
javascript and start using it with
tensorflow guests with that that brings
an end to my talk thank you so much for
attending this lightning talk thank you
so much
okay thanks for that talk let's do one
virtual round of applause
[Applause]
and uh i'm also while i'm setting up uh
the next speaker uh evgeny i'm asking
you to unmute the moment uh i also just
got a news article uh it seems like the
ceo of ikea has just been elected prime
minister of sweden which is going to be
very interesting because i assume that
the first thing he'll do is assemble a
cabinet um
okay can you see a
live mark
looking good on my side um so one round
of applause
take it away
yeah thank you
um yeah my name is uh kenny and hi
everyone
yep
happy to be here so
i'm an engineer at the open knowledge
foundation and we are working on the
open source project called frictions
data
we're open data advocates and we focus
on various projects related to data
standards uh interoperability and
software
so i think it will be kind of like a
break from from data science
talks here so
today i'd like to show you our new tool
uh
within our software toolbox called
wiremark
weimark is a python static site
generator that extends markdown this
interactive charts table scripts and
like other like many features
the main focus of the project is data
journalism software education and python
development assistance
for example documentation writing or
task running like
instead of make
uh it shortens a path from an idea to
published data driving portal or a
software documentation site
it had been inspired by project like
empty docs or whiz down
but
weimer's aim is to generalize the idea
of expressing like everything in
markdown so you just need to write your
markdown files i think it's kind of like
similar to air our
language style and environments
and
here we're just trying to bring it uh
this experience to python uh the project
is like really really new and yeah be
happy to present it for first time on
unconference but yeah
feel free to
like file an issue or report a bug
because
there are some
i'm pretty sure so
um show me the code um
here's a few
examples of what wiremark uh do on top
of uh markdown in general it supports
like normal markdown syntax uh github
flowers syntax and add various
extensions on top converting markdown
documents to
like a website html website that you can
publish for example on github pages
yeah for example here is a chart
declared in vega white notation which is
the main notation for charts in wire
mark
and
it's rendered as a chart here because
of the
chart
label in the
code block header
the same
for a table
so you can have like a csv in your
website like assets in you can show it
as an interactive table within a
wiremark website
you can also use uh ginger templating
from python uh i think you know um
ecosystem to um create kind of like a
markdown from team plates so you have a
c3 and you want to have like 100 items
list in markdown and you just use a
like simple ginger for loop and you'll
get a list in markdown
like can be like really one um
it can be like a list of charts or
tables so it's kind of like composable
uh there are around 20 other markdown
extensions for media present file
presentation more complex html using
bootstrap
and
like around to any other plugins for
appearance and navigation
um
let me show you
like
real site we created for
using wire mark it was more like a
showcase
but it has some like value value i think
itself it's a like no surprise uh covet
19 tracker because we just decided to
use this uh like really important topic
and
it showed the default uh wiremark layout
although it's like just a accepts from
other pages there there is a like normal
right
column and it's it's not a real column
it's just from other pages
um this spark tool contains various
kernel virus reports and covers all the
available countries including a separate
page for each country and
it took like less than a week a few days
to build and publish this project using
line work
everything there is written in
markdown
or why mark
so because you can just include into
markdown like html box it's it's it's
like you you anyway can include html
into markdown but in wire mark it's more
like uh
uh
it's easier to do and it's like we will
not break
charts
tables etc
yeah i encourage you to export this site
anymore there are some like really
interesting sections like rolling moon
team and
excess mortality
and the the next one
i'd like to show
it it wouldn't be
weird if you hadn't used weimar to write
documentation portal for wiremark itself
so of course we did
and it's again it's fully written in
line work and
it it's it's navigation search like
other interactive elements to the site
although it's just markdown documents uh
built with weimar
command-line interface uh command
um
yeah for example here is a
uh we have a pro universe and projects
in the universe section and it's a
listing created by ginger templates and
the data was uh
gathered from feed github api
um
currently the documentation site has
around like
two dozen pages while the build time is
around two three seconds on on an
ordinary laptop and it's kind of like a
big difference for
um
engines we used before like docker's
hours of view press for
our uh documentation
uh for local development ymca provides a
built-in live reward server
that speeds up documentation writing
and an important difference for using
weimark is that your documentation
becomes like testable every time you
build your site you test your your
documentation your snippets examples
like actually you can write like all
your tests in a while mark it's
something i think related to literature
programming uh by david newton
so
yeah
it's
i think it's also there is a software
education is a also great area for using
weimar because you can get your
educational materials like uh tested and
up to date
and the
rhymer is uh
really like usually pluggable
so
it's kind of like really small a few
lines of code to start adding your
like html or something to
your webmark project
um
and uh yeah as i said it's new and we
we're going to release version one
by the end of this year
and yeah please report any bugs you find
the project
yeah
really needs some feedback
share your thoughts and ideas it's of
course open source mit licensed and like
in general like collective effort of
people around open knowledge and
frictionless data
so yeah i think that's it thanks for
your time
thanks for that uh talk especially the
the yaml syntax for charts is definitely
a nice little feature there so
definitely well done um that also means
that we are now getting to the last
speaker uh of this session uh nico lo
and i'm going to ask you to unmute uh
yourself
um but uh and please start sharing your
screen um then as a final joke for this
session um i just learned that um
someone stole my mood ring um and i
don't know how i feel about that
um yes so um i wanted to talk about this
project i've been working on atesco
it's an experimental project and it's
really at the intersection between
i guess interpretable machine learning
data visualization and uh also
quantitative finance so it's an
interesting one
um
uh we had you know we learned a few
things in this space while working on it
so i wanted to share these these
learnings with all of you
um but first a few words around um
around tescos
um disco is the largest supermarket in
the uk with more than 3000 stores
between uk and ireland
and the data science team at disc really
works across the board in the business
supporting departments from supply chain
to
uh um you know transport and online so a
lot of interesting projects
um
we um
in this commodity project uh trading
project specifically uh we
um we wanted to provide a machine
learning model to support tesco's risk
management uh what does that mean sir
tesco buys every year a lot of
agriculture commodities
so things like um wheat corn sugar and
soybean and so on uh and the reason is
that cisco makes its own tesco branded
products and so of course
we need these these
commodities too to make them
now there is a bit risk big risk in
implicit in in this activity which is
the price of these commodities
so commodity prices are volatile and in
general are a big risk risk factor for
uh for retail companies
they can change for a number of reasons
from your climate reasons to
supply and demand problems or
speculations so for this reason tesco
created 10 years ago
a commodity team which is basically
a group of people a group of traders and
analysts who look at the commodity
market and try to predict the price
movements and try to predict whether the
price will go up in particular and if
they believe the price will go up they
try to protect this go from this change
in price by
doing things like hedging on the market
and setting price with the with the
suppliers also of course this this is
quite a hard problem predicting prices
in particular
so that's how the idea of a data science
solution came came about so with what
with this project we wanted to provide
um
a machine learning and to enter solution
that's uh by searching some uh data
through apis about you know again
whether
production and price would output the
probability of a price increase in the
future
as well as and more importantly a
database to interpret the model's
prediction
so that all of this could then feed back
to the commodity team as a further tool
they have to make their decisions and
being a bit more data-driven in their
decisions
so this is the general problem we wanted
to solve
one challenging part of this project was
that we had to deliver fast to learn
quickly so we had relatively uh
reasonable time to to develop the model
but then
we had had agreed with our data provider
at a trial period where we could use
their apis for free
and so we had a kind of a
hard deadline for
having a prototype of the end-to-end
solution ready so that we could make the
most of this trial period so around one
month so it wasn't a lot of time and we
couldn't do um
you know very sophisticated things in
that short time so we had to be creative
a little bit and that was also an
interesting part of that project that uh
it forced us to be creative and find
solutions that
have to be good enough of course for the
trial but um not not the full thing
um
so i will focus on the data vis just for
time constraints on of the problem so
i'll go through all the requirements we
have to meet in this in this trial and
how we solved uh those requirements and
um yeah so
the first requirement was of course the
model needed to be interpretable that
was very important because our
stakeholders the traders in the
commodity team needed to really
understand why the model was making a
certain prediction so that they could
use that prediction trusted prediction
and then use it in their decision
um so the the solution we adopted for
that was simply to open the black box of
the uh machine learning model with the
database library we use plotline in this
case um so we generated a number of
graphs um i guess the the most important
one was this this is a waterfall plot
showing how the prediction of the model
the blue bar breaks down into um
contribution for each feature
so that uh our stakeholders were able to
tell that um you know this this
prediction is is mostly driven by for
example uh weather data in this region
of the planet
uh or maybe supply and demand data in
this country and so on and also see the
sign of this feature so is this variable
pushing the price up or down and so on
and then we also added more complex
graphs for example this one on the
bottom
showing again the same feature
contribution breakdown but against time
over the last 10 months
again people could see trends there are
some variables some features that change
signs change their contribution to the
prediction
at one point they become more or less
important and all of this yeah helped a
lot the stakeholders build their trust
into the model sometimes they could
question question it and that was useful
but at least they could question it
knowing what's why the mother was making
these predictions and also was a great
tool for us to monitor the model in
production uh and slightly check the
model so that was a win-win
the second requirement was of course
this database needed to be accessible to
the stakeholders we couldn't just sit on
on our
notebook uh the natural solution for
that of course would be building a
dashboard but we didn't really have time
to do that and we didn't want to spend a
lot a long time just for a trial and you
know the project maybe wouldn't go
forward after after the uh trial anyway
so the simple solution we found was
actually quite effective was export
sport multiple uh subplots to an html
file and the result looks a lot like a
dashboard so it was quite uh quite good
and
much quicker than a dashboard so
impliedly you can use other libraries
too you can
create multiple subplots where you stack
different plots on top of each other and
then you simply export the figure as a
html file
the result looks as i said they look
like a dashboard so you open it on your
browser you can scroll
you can
scroll individual text boxes for
information about variables you can zoom
uh you can also defeat these features of
uh plotly you can select variables and
so on so to the hours the coolest this
really looked like a dashboard even
though it wasn't a dashboard
and as i said it was much easier for us
to create this
quicker and mostly um the big
disadvantage of this approach of course
is this is a static file so
if tomorrow the model makes new
prediction with new data of course this
file uh won't won't change because it's
just showing the data
you you fed in uh when you first created
the file so that was this leads me to
the third requirement in the third
solution so the third requirement was
this database needs to be promptly
updated every time new data come in
um and our solution here was to actually
use cloud services we use cloud services
to periodically update these html files
in the stakeholders folder so what does
that mean
um so this is the our pipe
final end-to-end solution so we have
this api to search data we have our
model here on on the cloud and this
service called azure machine learning
machine learning where we do inference
so we do plotting
we create this html file this lands into
a storage account and then we use a new
a second cloud service app called azure
logic app that
connects the storage account to the
sharepoint folder and also the email
inbox of our stakeholders so that uh
automatically this this new html file
lands in their share in their folder
so from the point of view of obvious the
caller is very neat so they they have
this file they can only open in their
browser and every uh pretty much every
day they have a new fresh new html file
with new data they don't even realize
it's it's just so all happening
kind of behind the scenes thanks to the
cloud technology here um and kind of the
this creative use of the cloud
technology
um so yeah that's pretty much it so um
the conclusions i guess the take-home
message i wanted to
convey was that a static html5 plus
cloud services can make a great rough
and ready dashboard that is not really a
dashboard but it's great good enough for
proof of concepts and trials
and then
you really set out to set this up in a
day and then
if the you know business is happy with
the result then you can you know crack
on with the actual dashboard and invest
timing on a server and so on
um our project was successful in that we
um
stakeholders fee because good the
model's performance was good um so the
business is now deciding whether the
commercial
benefit is good enough to
to move on and if they do if they decide
to do that we'll yeah as i said migrate
the database to a proper dashboard now
that we have time uh explore more
complex architectures and more
commodities
and that's it i will just conclude
saying we are hiring a disco so if you
are interested get in touch uh on the
website tesco careers or get in touch
with these people
thank you
that was a really i really liked the
chart you had back there actually the
the the i can definitely imagine how
drift is easily detect the detected
there
uh but with that said uh this was the
final speaker in our uh lightning talk
series um
so what i would like to do is just end
with a cute little poem that someone
shared on the part of the global slack
roses are red i feel the burn i used a
deep learning tool i should have used
scikit-learn i thought it was kind of a
cute one to end with
thanks all the speakers for sharing
their ideas and thanks to all the
listeners once again thanks everyone and
see you around the conference